my name is Fernando reamers and I chair
the Global Agenda Council for you
creation of the formula yaad I'm
delighted to answer your question which
is even that Latin America has a very
high youth unemployment rate how can it
increase opportunities for young people
indeed I think that creating the
conditions will include youth in both
economically socially and political is
absolutely essential not just as a basic
human right of those people but in order
to have democratic governance and
political stability in the region and I
think that there are short-term and
medium-term things that can be done one
of them is to promote the development of
entrepreneurial skills and of conditions
that would allow I would allow young
people to create work for themselves and
for others to look at the provision of
an infrastructure that can provide very
specific skill sets that would help
people develop the agency and have the
capacity to add value by creating
enterprises economic enterprises and
social enterprises by providing access
to capital and to the networks that can
help them scale up those enterprises
long-term it is absolutely imperative
that schools at the elementary middle
school high school level and at the
college level have many more
opportunities for students to work in
the solution of real problems and to use
what they know
apply that to the solution and the
creation of innovations to address
important social and economic
imperatives and in doing that I think it
will be possible for the future
generations of young people in the
region to have the kinds of
intrapreneurial skills that will allow
them to make to build a vibrant and
inclusive economy and politics